one of the number one gifts that God
gives us is the opportunity to have free
will and to make decisions for ourselves
he said you get to decide if you want to
take up your cross and follow me you get
to decide if you want to live a life of
worship you get to decide if you want to
believe that my son actually came down
on Earth to die for you that is your
decision and I'm not forcing that upon
you you put a pause there yes we do have
free will and we can either turn our
will toward God and cooperate with God's
grace and do things that are conducive
to our flourishing here on Earth and in
heaven so that we can enjoy God forever
or we can abuse our Free Will and turn
away from God and burn in hell for
eternity so she's right as often the
woke religion people will be they'll
have like a little tiny kernel of an
almost truth in there somewhere but then
they will come to the completely wrong
conclusions and ignore the point of that
which is which is also that actions have
consequences